The ship is totally repaired.
We can finally leave
this shithole planet.
So long Earth suckers.
Enjoy the melting ice caps.
No no no no no no no no no no
[SCREAMING]
[CRASH]
Dammit.
Yay!
We're still trapped on Earth.
This puts us right back to
where we were a year ago.
Oh my God make a
bigger deal about it.
I'm just glad everything
is back to normal.
Yo, dork.
Are you crazy?
Where are your masks?
I didn't know we needed masks.
I've been breathing
air for over a year.
[SPITTING]
Let's get the hell out of here.
Quick grab a scooter.
[BEEPS]
[WHIRRING]
What the fuck is that?
It's called big dick
energy and when I get it
I'll be unstoppable.
I don't know a big dick
seems really dangerous.
Run.
Everyone run.
I can't control it.
I'll come and I'll
blow you away.
It's the Shlorpian
distress call.
We have to help them.
Looks like the Solar
Opposites are going to London.
What could go wrong?
Suck my butt, Officer Asshole.
The Solar Opposites
are going to jail.
He doesn't have a hole.
We'll just have to make one.
I came here to--
How are we still so bad at this?
I don't want to point
fingers at the weak link
here but get your
shit together, Pup.
[LASER BLASTS]
[YELLING]
[SPLAT]
This is going to be awesome.
We're in the big city.
You can be anything you want out
here, super hero, politician,
orthodontist, a prostitute.
You want to have
some fun, sugar?
No fucking way.
I came here to play.
Release your unholy creation.
Are these from Brooklyn?
[CRASH]
[SCREAMING]
Play, play.
We're turning people into wine?
These people love wine.
Look how happy they
are on the labels
Play, play, play, play.